hi I'm bill green from accenture I just
come out of an incredibly energizing and
engaging session and what we can do how
do we leverage the cloud to improve you
know that both business and social
conditions and opportunities in Latin
America it was an incredibly powerful
session and people continue to be in the
room it just engaged in the topic we
talked about a lot of things first we
started with you know what are the
opportunities to write education to the
next generation of people in places
around the world how do we provide
access in other words how do we reach we
talked about the ability to improve
health care services we talked about the
ability for entrepreneurs to start
businesses we talked about the ability
for larger companies to reinvent their
business models all leveraging the
technologies that are available today
around the cloud we also know that
focused also on some of the some of the
challenges it's an engineering solution
it's pretty straightforward but we do
have some challenges that we talked
about openly we have challenges of first
coverage having the broadband necessary
to support it we talked about challenges
of scalability reliability security
and privacy all very real conversations
we have a minister of information and
communications here with us to lay out
some of the challenges we talked about
how business and government that society
needs to work together on this journey
we talked about the fact is it is a
journey and not a destination and we're
going to learn as we go we are very and
the room was very grateful to the forum
for putting this on the agenda and for
the work it was done up to Davos and the
report coming out of Davos it provides a
lot of direction and guidance to
companies and people in this space we
talked about the fact that pilot
projects are an important part of it but
at the end of the day I think the thing
that mattered was people had a
realization that you know technology has
the capability to be leveraged to change
how the world works and lives and that
this cloud computing phenomenon
everything about the cloud ecosystem it
just has an incredible amount of power
not only in improving business
productivity but improving social
productivity as well in this sense I
think we all realize that the delivery
systems of the world the systems that
deliver health care that deliver
education deliver public services and
liver cancer services are real that the
old ones are really at their breaking
point and we need to not renew but
reinvent the world's delivery systems
how do we reach more people how do we
reach them in a more effective way and
how do we have a bigger impact and
people can see very clearly that the
cloud is a technology as it allows us to
provide new ways of delivering goods and
services to the people in the world and
can accelerate the development and a
country like Brazil in a region like
Latin America we had comments from
Panama and Costa Rica and Argentina from
many countries in this region about
things they're doing pilots or other
initiatives they've taken and you can
feel and see the momentum building we
finally closed with a discussion not
only of the cloud
but recognizing that sustainability
continues to be a very important item
all around the world and if you think
about smart grids and how we get power
and in order to operate the cloud wean
one power essentially smart grid
technology right is the internet for
power and how do we make sure as you
think about the cloud that the early
pioneers of using the cloud are also
thinking about not only to how we
provision the capability how do we
provide it in a sustainable and
efficient way and that the fact that
cloud lends itself to embracing some of
the other things we're trying to get
done around sustainability and around
efficiency and around our climate so we
have a very unique opportunity here to
bring together two incredibly important
initiatives to raise the bar if you will
in providing people the opportunity to
raise their their their capabilities and
then to improve how the world works and
lives but it was an incredibly
energizing focus session I think the
people that attended are incredibly
grateful analysts were in a class by
themselves and I think this is the topic
that we're going to continue to talk
about for the years to come more
importantly we're going to continue to
see the results flying
all the related technologies to
improving how the world works so thank
you very much